Dwayne the rock Johnson I've known him
for that while we did a film in 2010
called tooth fairy you're welcome Julie
Andrews yes he's the tooth fairy and I'm
his probation officer what didn't find
out trilogy or did you stick with the
first one we went with the only we went
just for the one to do to public demand
but yes so i am i neither rock before
you know but when he was still in shape
and and we stay in touch over the years
we've you know we're this was surprising
we're not gym buddies I barely work out
at all I know it's hard to believe he
was in England and he was making fast
and furious 6 here and he was in this is
a story told me that he's in a hotel and
he saw this he was in this hotel I
assumed it was the Presidential Suite of
you know the Travel Lodge and and he's
you know he's brought his own bottled
water he's not made of money and his
hotel places he's not the free
shortbread and he's put on the sort of
thing you know that free robe they give
you yeah Bailey it barely covers his is
Dwayne Johnson we're good friends I know
though for that I don't know whether
that's way cause it you might you might
call it the rock good
I would so he's watching British TV on
channel 4 he's watching channel 4 in
particular he never misses high hopes
this documentary comes on about this
family this fact this real-life family
of British wrestlers her from Norwich
England they called the the Beavis
family they sometimes go as the Knights
and there they are they all wrestle mum
dad and all the kids and the family
dream was to get some of the kids into
WWE which you know is the big American
wrestling which for wrestlers is the big
leagues only the daughter Paige got
signed brothers that got left behind and
and what the story dramatized is this
this really kind of funny sweet
uplifting inspiring story of her journey
going off to the States and trying to
climb all the way to the top of the WWE
so carrying the dreams of both her
family and herself yeah on her shoulders
you know and I love that contest being
kind of Norwich right and America and
the Zach all the bells and whistles wait
which one of the family did the rock
play thank you good question no so the
rock in real life was involved with
their story and so he plays himself in
the movie I didn't want the rock to play
the rock I didn't think use the man for
the job
I've been diesel but he wasn't available
he's also producer
[Music]
you